russia is by far the most advanced uh
foreign adversary
sending manipulative messages over
social media they're
even more nuanced today than they were
in 2016 and we are no more prepared
today
than we were in 2016.
hey wired i'm sin onoral i'm the david
austin professor of management at mit
director of mit's initiative on the
digital economy and author of the hype
machine
about how social media disrupts our
world and i'm here to debunk some myths
about the role of social media in
elections and specifically in the
upcoming
election of 2020.
social media sways elections did russia
sway the election of 2016. we know they
sent
manipulative messages to 126 million
people on facebook
20 million on instagram and 10 million
tweets
do these things sway the election
there's really three things to know
does it change vote choice does it
change voter turnout
and is the reach scope and targeting
of misinformation or campaign
information
enough to sway an election voter choice
is simply who you choose to
vote for given that you're voting do you
vote for republicans or democrats that's
a vote choice
the evidence on vote choice is
relatively clear
social media messaging and digital
advertising in general has a very small
to negligible to zero effect on vote
choice
voter turnout on the other hand is do
you choose to vote at all
and the number of people who vote in an
election and there
the evidence is a little bit scarier in
the sense that
large-scale experiments have shown that
social media messages
digital advertising can have
statistically significant
effects on voter turnout facebook ran an
experiment
with 61 million people in it in 2010
which showed that with a simple message
they could create
votes in uh congressional elections that
wouldn't have happened without their
message
they replicated that experiment in 2012
and demonstrated again
the ability for social media to create
voter turnout
many studies indicate how digital
messaging can get out the vote
and that's an important part of changing
or swaying
elections targeting is who you direct
digital social media messages to which
populations
in which regions and which districts uh
in the voting electorate
the evidence in 2016 indicated that
russian
interference was targeted at swing
states and
that the reach and scope of it was large
enough
to affect voters in a way that could
change the election
through voter turnout in addition we
know
that a lot of the manipulative messages
sent by russia in 2016
were about voter suppression voter
suppression memes
tend to be targeted at specific
communities so for instance we know that
in 2016
on instagram in particular
african-american
voters were targeted with voter
suppression memes indicating for example
hillary clinton is not a fan of the
black voter
and therefore we should stay home or
there's really no one to vote for in
this election there's no reason to vote
those types of memes were targeted
through at mentions
at communities that were
african-american or
in this year's election followed the
black lives matter movement
and so on trying to suppress specific
communities of voters in key swing
states
the number one culprit in spreading
misinformation and voter suppression
memes in 2016 and likely in 2020
is russia while russian misinformation
was
scary in the 2016 election they are much
more sophisticated today than they were
four years ago in addition this is
happening during a global pandemic
with civil unrest in the streets arising
from the justifiable social movements
against police brutality in the united
states
with all of this uncertainty we are at a
dramatic risk for foreign interference
in our election in 2020.
and of course social media is nowhere
near
the only factor affecting elections
certainly the candidates their charisma
their policies
advertising their ability to connect
with voters as well as
news of the day what is hitting the
pocketbooks and the
homes and families of everyday voters
obviously has the largest effect social
media spreads fake news
faster than the truth that's true we did
a
10-year longitudinal study of all of the
verified true and false news that spread
on twitter between
2006 and 2017. in fact we found
that false news was 70 percent more
likely to be retweeted
and false news traveled about six times
faster
than true news online fake news is not a
new term it was not
invented by donald trump in fact it
first appeared i believe
in a harper's magazine news story
and we've had uh the concept of falsity
in
journalism for many years and decades
prior to today
the thing that makes today different
however is the speed and breadth and
depth with which
social media can spread fake news so
much faster than the truth online
and how that can be targeted at specific
individuals and communities
creating separate realities for people
who are seeing one type of news in one
community
and a different type of news in a
different community so when we found
these results in our twitter data the
natural next question
for us was why why does fake news spread
so much farther faster deeper and more
broadly than the truth
and what we came up with was what we
call the novelty hypothesis
so if you read the cognitive science
literature you know
that human attention is drawn to novelty
new things in the environment
and if you read the sociology literature
you know that
we gain in status when we share novel
information because it makes us look
like we're
in the know or that we have inside
information that other people don't have
so these two factors uh make it more
likely that we share novelty so when we
check the novelty of true and false news
compared to everything
that a given individual on twitter had
seen in the two months prior we found
that indeed
false news was way more novel than the
truth and when we checked the replies to
true and false tweets to see how people
were
expressing sentiment about what they
were reading we found that indeed in
reply to false news
people expressed surprise anger and
disgust
while in reply to true news they
expressed anticipation joy and trust
so the surprise confirmed our novelty
hypothesis
that yes false news is more novel people
spread
more novel information more often than
less novel information
and people were genuinely surprised by
fake news
voting booths are not hackable
false voting booths can be hacked have
been hacked
and abnormal ballot results in a number
of examples over the last
decade or so in the united states many
people believe that because the united
states
has a federalist system in which each
state
tallies its votes in its own way uses
different computer systems
that there's no centralized tallying of
ballots that this somehow
protects the american voting system from
hacking at the voting booth itself but
that's not true
it just means that there are 50
different types of systems that a hacker
can attack
so for instance we know that in 2016
a hacker named cyberzeist hacked the
alaska voting systems and
claimed that he could change the voting
tallies in any direction that he wanted
in alaska there are also a number of
myths surrounding voting that are
spreading on social media the
major one is that there is widespread
voter fraud
there is no real evidence of a
systematic voter fraud at the level of
ballots
or other types of voter fraud people
voting
twice dead people voting and so on
although there have been
a very very small handful of
incidents that may have happened where
there is an error on a ballot there has
been
no evidence of systematic voter fraud
since we can remember
about elections in the united states
which means that
despite all of the myths floating around
social media
we as citizens can be confident in the
integrity of our elections
so my advice to all of us is that we
vote and vote as quickly as possible
ahead of november 3rd social media
algorithms are dividing our society
there is
evidence that recommendation algorithms
that social media uses
does tend to give us more of what we
want and therefore
lock us into narrower and narrower sets
of
information filter bubbles refers to the
fact that in an
algorithmic world we are each living in
our
own information bubble meaning
that what i see on social media is not
what you see
and not what what your friends see
because everything that you see
is tailored to you and it's tailored to
you
by algorithms that are designed to give
you more of what you want
to keep you engaged that creates these
filter bubbles
of information that are unique to every
individual
echo chambers are groups or communities
of people
that are sharing the same information
over and over again with each other
and that that information stays locked
in that community
and doesn't cross over for instance to
the other side of the aisle
where different information is being
constantly shared amongst
a different set of people so there are
certain algorithms for instance the
youtube algorithm that tends to
recommend
more and more of the type of content
that you seem engaged with and
interested in
studies have shown that these types of
algorithms
can tend to lead to more extreme content
being shown
to the viewer these algorithms are
designed to be bottomless or endless
meaning they keep you engaged in a
constantly updating reel of new videos
while the jury is out on whether this
can radicalize someone or the degree to
which there are systematic
extremism outcomes that are created by
these algorithms
the fact that they are sending you down
rabbit holes
of more and more content similar to what
you like and engage with
is troubling given the notion of the
filter bubble
in order to fight the filter bubble we
have to seek out
diverse content we have to follow people
whose opinions are different than our
own
we have to do searches for content that
is
contrary to what we believe we have to
demonstrate to the hype machine to the
social media industrial complex that
we're interested
in diversity and that we are seeking
diversity or
opinions that are different from our own
that will help us
break out of the filter bubbles that we
find ourselves in
with these algorithms you can easily
spot a deep fake
deep fakes are synthetic video that are
generated by machine learning algorithms
called
generative adversarial networks these
networks have
a generator and a discriminator where
the discriminator's job is to tell
real from fake videos and the generator
tries to generate more and more
convincing synthetic video
till it fools the discriminator into
believing that it's
true now the problem with deep fakes is
that they're
more difficult to spot every day that
goes by
there are instances of audio deep fakes
where companies have been defrauded out
of millions of dollars
where the cfo will be called by a
synthetic attacker that is using the
voice of the ceo
requesting that large sums of money be
transferred before the end of the
quarter or to close a deal
the reason why deep fakes are so
troubling is because
seeing is believing and a picture is
worth a thousand words
i have seen some incredibly
professionally created and convincing
deep fakes for instance of
president barack obama or mark
zuckerberg
or prime minister boris johnson or kim
jong-un
that really kind of skate the line
between
is this convincing or is this not as
deep fakes become
more commonplace as the technology used
to create them becomes more democratized
and more people have access to it
i think we're going to see a rise of a
wave of synthetic audio and video that
could become
very dangerous in a political
environment or in a commercial
environment
either through fraud or through
political manipulation
i think the most effective way to spot a
deep fake
is to uh distinguish the content
of what's being said in the film if you
can't imagine
those words coming out of the mouth of
the person that you're viewing
that is a good sign that this is a deep
fake social media can bring about
positive change most recently we've been
focused on the potential disasters that
social media can create in our world
but it's important not to forget about
the tremendous
potential for promise that social media
can also bring
we know for instance that when nepal
experienced the
greatest earthquake that it's seen in a
hundred years facebook spun up a donate
now button and raised
15.5 million dollars from 770
000 people in over a hundred countries
which just shows you the mobilization
potential
of this technology it's certainly played
a catalyzing
and accelerant role in important social
movements around the world like black
lives matter the arab spring
the snow revolution in russia social
mobilization
in japan and hong kong and these kinds
of social movements can really
be accelerated by social media
research at mit and at stanford shows
that facebook creates 370 billion
dollars a year
in consumer surplus in the united states
alone
imagine that for the entire world
that's economic opportunity that's the
ability to find jobs
access to life-saving health information
and real human connection
in some countries around the world
facebook is the internet it's the way
that people conduct
any number of human activities from
market transactions to running their
businesses to staying in touch with
their friends and family
or finding out about where to vote or
how to get health care
these types of benefits are actually
tremendous social media is a very
powerful tool
for creating such change in society the
real question is
what are we going to use it for are we
going to use it for the nefarious
purposes that we've seen it be used for
recently
or we're going to use it to bring about
a better world